I don't like the new auditor I like the
old old intern can't you mix the music
from the old old intro with the new old
intro music what I spent quite a while
making that new old intro but you didn't
like it so I'm too nice and I've made a
new new old intro not only the Hat but
I've also changed my outro as well oh my
god i from this point on I vow never
ever ever ever to talk about intros or
outros or theme tunes or anything like
that ever again it will be a forbidden
topic on this channel right let's get on
with the video Johnny it's so Charlie
yes so Charlie is so cool ten thousand
subscribers if I could say thank you for
the entire generation of this video I
would but it'd be very long and really
boring now I've been thinking what kind
of video could I do to thank 10,000
subscribers so there's a little treat
for you all for all my 10,000 was ten
thousand and five bad moment of
recording thank you all as a treat for
your all I thought I'd show you a video
from my past today I'm going to show you
the first ever video I uploaded onto
YouTube but Charlie why would you do
that surely if we wanted to see your
first ever video we could just look
through your old videos it's not the
case guys because my first ever video I
took it off YouTube my first ever video
that I posted was a advert well like an
advert kind of trailer thing for a short
film that me and my friend were going to
make that's the reason I started YouTube
in the first place because I wanted to
upload a short film it's just something
that me and my friend were going to do
over the holidays but we never got
around to doing it and to be honest we
just got bored we wanted to get it to be
a short film but we cooked up like half
an hour's worth footage and we're only
like halfway through so we just kind of
gave up but while we were still involved
in the whole video making process this
is the video making process I decided to
make a trailer thing there it is earnest
guys enjoy
I'm a machine chisel me down until I am
clean I buy books I never read and then
I'll tell you some more about
yes yes I know
I like Nintendo too much don't you damn
Oakley then 10 I make good games okay
I love soda just shut up guys just shut
up stop teasing me